Tarik Cohen's comin' to New York
to eat
at a Jewish deli
with Simms and Lefkoe?
Oy vey!
♪♪
When I heard there was a guy
in the NFL, Simms
named Tarik Cohen,
I said, "Mwah.
L'chaim. We've got ourselves
finally, a Jewish running back,"
and then I found out
not only have you never been
to a bar mitzvah
not only have you never had
Jewish food, you're not Jewish.
- Sadly, no.
I appreciate the "sadly."
- Yeah.
- "Cohen" though.
I mean, that's in the
Mount Rushmore of Jewish names.
- It really is.
- I am 100 percent Jewish.
- Yeah.
- What I want to give to you
is the full Jewish experience.
I can call it a Jewish combine
to making you feel
like a true Jewish man.
Are you ready to take
this journey with me?
- Oh, yeah, I'm definitely ready.
- OK.
- L'chaim.
- L'chaim!
♪♪
[Bell dinging]
- This is our first dish.
This is a customary
Jewish breakfast.
Do you want to take a guess
as to what
is in front of you right now?
- Sushi.
It is not sushi.
It is smoked salmon.
What do you think of it?
- Cream cheese and fish?
- Exactly.
- Man.
- Yes, "man" is right.
- All right, so
don't be afraid of it.
- No, I'm not.
- So why don't you pick it up?
- Oh, that was a——oh, my gosh.
- Hold on.
- I don't like it.
- You don't?
Do you mind if I have a bite?
- Damn.
- You can have all the bites.
- Ugh.
- I mean, it's perfect.
This is a Jewish deli staple,
and it's not just what it is—
- [Laughing] His eyes.
- It's the size of it, OK?
- Yeah.
- This is a pastrami on rye.
And do you see
how much meat is on that?
- Yeah.
- That's not just special.
- It's a little excessive.
- Can't miss it.
- He looked at that like it was
a blitzing linebacker
when it came in.
He, like, literally looked at it
and was like—
- Why don't you bite into that?
- All right.
Let's see, which one—hmm.
- And this is part of the process,
too
the strategy of how
to bite the sandwich.
- I can see that.
- I'm gonna go ahead
and try to flatten him.
- Nice.
I think he's gonna like this.
- You think he'll like it?
- I feel pretty
confident about it.
- I really give him credit
for havin' the guts
to just dive in there, though.
- Why is there no cheese
or nothin' on it though?
Cheese, mayonnaise
or somethin'?
- Well, that wouldn't be kosher.
We have one more.
This is the Cadillac
of Jewish food.
Tarik Cohen,
I'd like to introduce you
to your new favorite food,
matzo ball soup.
- Matzo ball.
Have you heard
of matzo balls before?
- Mozzarella?
- Mozzarella
not the same thing.
This is not cheese.
- There's no cheese in there?
- There's no cheese.
You thought matzo balls
had cheese, too?
- I totally did.
- So the best way to do this
is to take your spoon
take a little piece
of the matzo ball
get a little bit
of soup in there.
- Oh, it's soft.
- It's very soft.
♪♪
And there it is.
- That's good.
- That's the 10 out of 10.
- It's like chicken noodle soup,
really.
- It's chicken noodle soup.
♪♪
The second part of our
Jewish combine is Jewish slang.
- OK.
- Not only do I want you to eat
like a Jew,
I want you to talk like a Jew.
So here's the first word.
- This is gonna be fun.
- It is.
- Schmooth.
- Schmooze.
What do you
think schmooze means?
- Good sleep.
- Good sleep?
Oh, like a—
- Man, I'mma go schmooze.
- I'mma go schmooze.
- I'm about to schmooze.
- So, a schmooze is actually
to, like, kinda
talk somebody up.
- "Hey, I like your play calls,
Matt Nagy."
- Yeah.
- "That's a really creative one."
- "Throw me the ball."
- You're schmoozing him so he
gives you the ball.
- You're schmoozing, yeah.
- You schmooze, you win.
- Right.
- Next word. Ooh!
Good luck sayin' this one.
- Chootz-pah.
- Hootz-pah.
- Ah, chutzpah.
- You gotta get a "heh."
- Chutzpah!
- Oh!
- "We were in the team meeting
and Tarik Cohen stood up
and said
'I don't like that play.'
Tarik's got a lot of chutzpah."
- Like, balls.
- Yeah.
- Exactly. This is the Jewish
slang phrase of all generations.
- Oy vey.
What do you think it is?
- "Tarik Cohen was supposed to run
the slant route
and he ran the go route.
Oy vey, Tarik Cohen."
- Or it's like,
"All those pickles for me?
Oy vey."
- Oh, yeah, I got you.
So it's good and bad.
- It can be everything.
- OK, good.
That's the one
I'mma use right there.
- You have aced
the Jewish combine.
And I have a gift for you.
- Oy vey.
I give you
a Chicago Bears yarmulke.
- It's a Jewish fitted cap.
- A Jewish fitted cap, yes.
Oh, my gosh,
it looks so beautiful.
- Perfect.
- Simms, you're not out of here.
- Oooh.
- A Giants yarmulke.
- I like it.
- Put that bad boy on.
- Yeah!
- And I have an Eagles yarmulke.
Now we celebrate.
Let's give it up for him.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
- Hey!
- L'chaim!